Film Courage: Are you a worst-case scenario type of person?
Jay Fingers, Screenwriter/Author: I
definitely am. It's a good way to be.
Film Courage:
What's the worst-case scenario for your
screenwriting career here in Los Angeles, Jay?
Jay: The worst case scenario would would be
that I've done all of this for nothing. That I
never write anything that gets made or that
gets sold or that turns into something that
people see my goal is is to become a professional
screenwriter that's what I would like to do and
as long as I can write and I'm able to make that
my living I can make a living as a screenwriter
that's that's fine but yeah if it just never
happens for me that's worst case scenario I
can't think of anything worse than that I've
read stories and and and seen interviews with
people who say that they've written and they've
made money and and nothing's ever ever been made
from what they've written it's like oh I've been
commissioned to write this and rewrite this and
nothing was ever made made a lot
of money but nothing was ever made
in a situation like that I feel that there's
there's there's always a way to get something
made though if I'm able to make a living as a
screenwriter but say none of the projects that
I've been working on the studio or the producer
they they decide that they don't want to make it
I think then I would just try to make something on
my own I'm still making a living as a screenwriter
but at least then I would have I think the ability
to then perhaps do something on my own even if
it's a short film you see what I'm saying because
I'm taking care of myself I'm earning money
doing what I love to do as my passion and
that gives me then the freedom then to maybe
explore over here to do something else over
here I don't know if that makes sense but
it does do you think the words what if
and it you you stayed in Tennessee nothing
wrong with Tennessee but or somewhere else
maybe settle down in Miami and never
tried would be worse oh well I sure
I'm I don't mean to put words no no no no it's
just like okay if I'm thinking worst case scenario
worst case scenario is me pursuing screenwriting
and never achieving that goal never becoming a
professional screenwriter but me staying in
Tennessee or New York or Miami just never pursuing
it at all well there is no worst case scenario in
that scenario because I'm not chasing the dream
that's how I would look at it sure but if you
still had it inside you would you just ah the
odds are it won't happen like if it's inside
me then then I'm gonna go for it sure that's
that's that's with that's with any any endeavor
that I have like if it's in me to do something
believe me I'm gonna I'm gonna chase it I'm gonna
what does the 90-year-old Jay Fingers say in a
conversation to the j fingers sitting here now
and this 90 year old jay fingers never
pursued screenwriting never got out of his
comfort zone never risked being alone maybe
turning down a great night at TGI Fridays
what's that conversation like
what I think in that conversation
the 90 year old jay would probably be proud and
say at least you you tried you you gave it a shot
you went out there and and and you followed your
dream even though that dream perhaps cost you
everything at least you tried so yeah I think
that 90 year old jay would would be proud okay
all right so if we if we're traveling ahead in
time and and he he's like consoling the jay that's
here now or not even consoling but just giving
him praise for for going for it and keep going and
I like what you said you said if it meant you
had to make something of your own even if it
was a short that would be okay and then just do
polishes or rewrites for other people right and
that's a lot of people's careers and I don't think
that's a failure but everybody has their own bar
of what right right what success is okay I and and
just the reason why I mentioned that is because
I feel like in those interviews that
I've read and seen where people say
this is this is yeah I've had a great
career but nothing was ever made
I don't know I just don't get that I feel
like the opportunity is there just like I
said like a short or or something it may not
be the big massive 4,000 screens premiere but
but it is something and then I feel like that's
that's why we get into this business is we want
to create and tell stories especially in film you
want people to see your work so I feel just feel
like the opportunity is there to create something
that can be seen what is a chaotic neutral
there's this matrix that has
I guess different personality
traits or whatever and you've got like lawful
good the lawful good person is the person that
will follow the letter of the law and
they they're a good nice good person
and then you've got like I forget what the the
opposite is it's evil I guess unlawful evil where
you just whatever so on this matrix I feel I fall
in chaotic neutral right I'm not a goody two-shoes
but I'm not an evil person either I'm just I'm
me I fall in the middle as far as that goes
as far as chaotic I'm just I'm I feel like I'm
a bit all over the place I'm into different
things I like different things I do different
things I sometimes act on spur of the moment
sometimes I will turn down an invitation
for potato skins and cocktails
then sometimes i'll show up and you you won't
expect it like jay what are you doing here so
that's that's that's kind of what by
chaotic neutral I don't know if that's
really the definition but that's how
I that's how I define it for myself
what would you say is the personality type
of most of the characters you've created
the protagonists I would say most
of them are a little little chaotic
but they would probably fall a little
closer to the good side of the matrix
I think most of my protagonists have good hearts
best intentions for people I think that most of
my characters most of my protagonists
I think they actually do sacrifice for
those that they love those that they care about
which makes me wonder if I'm projecting a little
wish fulfillment on to them just like
ah this is this is who I’d like to be
in that respect but yeah most of my
characters are are pretty pretty good people
yeah and where is this where did this make this
personality matrix where did this come from
I don't remember I saw it online somewhere
and people were filling filling out the
quiz to get the the results and I just
thought it was funny I just thought it
was funny I was like no I'm chaotic neutral
I already know where I fall on this spectrum.